và chăm tính giò trả chữ hàng thè đã được bán ra thị trường và bản có thể tình nâng phải.
Kìm chát độ xuất cơ sở tình rõnh giò trả trên phố Minh thiện thuật phương hoàn kým,
lực lượng trức năng bắt quả tăng tại đây đang sản xuất bà tạo giò trả có chữ hàng thè,
loại phụ ra bị cấm sự dụng trong chi bến thực phẩm.
Tại cơ quan điều trả, chủ cơ sở khai nhận dung hàng thè và quá trình chi bến từ năm 2020,
sản xuất thương và chăm tính sản phẩm bán ra thị trường.
Trung trò tình thè vàng dự đối mở để kè bị ra xay phạc,
mới cân thiệt tìm cho tí tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tì tò.
Hàn thè là chất độ khai, thương bị làm giúp trong thực phẩm để tạo cảm giác giòn,
dài bảo quản được lâu hơn.
Sư dụng nhiều cóm quy cơ tổn tương nè và suy giảm chỉ tệ.
Lực lượng chất năng đang mở giúp điều trà sử lý theo quy định.